thank you
all right let's try pushing the wrong
button
this one's got two all right good
evening uh welcome uh this evening now
there isn't going to be uh
a scheduled fire drill tonight so if if
an alarm does activate we just leave the
building by the nearest fire excerpt and
through the main doors and we will
assemble in front of the main entrance
the building at a suitable safe distance
uh don't collect any belongings and do
not return to the building until given
permission uh please note that this
meeting will be live streamed and please
switch off mobile phones or put them on
silent
um and note that the toilet and hand
washing facilities are available on the
fire foia area
there is a need to use microphones and
when I invite you to speak species
please speak clearly and
um the microphones are needed for the
hearing Loop and for the live stream
voting will be done as a show of hands
in line with the Constitution I'll ask
for a show of hands and then against
recommendations I'll also ask for a show
of hands for those wishing to abstain
from voting
and then we move on to item one which is
apologies for absence
we've had apologies from councilor Mr
Carter and councilor Nick Booth there's
only one
right agenda item two is substitute
members
there are now
and agenda item 3 non-members attending
they're on
an agentum item four are the minutes of
the meeting held on the 14th of March
this year members are the minutes agreed
thank you
sign those in due course
right a gentum item five is to receive
Declarations of Interest are there any
Declarations of interest from members
no they're all now
agenda item six
is the internal audit report for 2023
and members Mike Porter Chief audit
executive will introduce the report
and after that if you've got any
questions
um
just show by show your hand thank you
thank you sorry
thank you very much
the annual audit report for 2223 is a
key documents in terms of the
government's framework in that it
provides an overview of all opinion on
the council's arrangements through a
governance internal control and risk
management this opinion also feeds into
the annual government statement
so if I can take you back sort of 12
months or so
um present it to this committee is the
audit plan that prior to the
commencement of the new Financial year
which sets out all the audits we're
going to undertake for that Financial
year so it's a plan of activity it's a
risk-based plan that sets out all the
audience we're planning or proposing to
undertaking that Financial year
um you may recall that in July of 2022
we created a shared internal audit
surface between Roger and Basildon
Council at that time we inherited
somewhat of a a problem in that the
principal orders at that time who worked
for Rockford Council was leaving the
authority and that presented me with the
task of going out to recruit for his
replacement
um as members may recall this causes a
number of significant issues and
problems in that the markets quite
depressed and trying to find a skilled
um
it also proves somewhat difficult um we
started to advertising around July and
only managed to secure a placement in
January 2020-23 so it took in excess of
about six seven months to find that
replacement so as a result I've been
reduced audit resources for that period
of time we had to present a revised
audit plan to this committee and so we
couldn't deliver the original plan set
out in March and we brought a revised
audit plan to this committee
um we have managed to basically pre
achieve that revised audit plan the
original audit plan itself is set out at
appendix one so appendix one is the
original audit plan and we also detail
as part of that plan what audits were
deferred as a result of a lack of audit
resources so we actually ended up
deferring only six items two of those
items as a result of the lack of
resources and a further forward it's
worthy for deferred until the following
year as a request of Senior Management
as a result of ongoing service reuse so
it's felt beneficial to actually defer
those audits until 23 24 because because
the ongoing service reviews
so in terms of what have we done we've
managed to complete um 17 audit reviews
and these are detailed at 6.3
so of those 17 audit reviews
two received a good Assurance ranking
five adequate Unlimited
one received positive direction of
travel
six audits basically we didn't provide
an opinion because there are more of a
Conservancy type and we also undertook
two Grant reviews
um a house have been a bit subsidy
so in terms of my opinion I'm providing
an adequate Assurance view in that the
council's arrangements for risk
management governance internal control
are a sound and basically
um everything's work is it should it's
all good it probably causes proper
practice so we're giving adequate
Assurance
um
unless unless it's essentially things
were giving me significant good reasons
for concern we wouldn't give a limited
Assurance review so basically adequate
sounds sort of like middle of the road
is satisfactory so basically things are
fundamentally sound and are called
proper practice also on the I suppose
Converse that is unlikely we're ever
going to give basically a substantial
Assurance rating because there's always
areas for improvement so adequate
although it sounds like middle of the
road it's satisfactory of things
fundamentally sound and the court of
proper Raptors so what we're saying
things are okay
you know no major concerns no major
issues for myself
um in addition to that since I last
report to committee we've completed
um
a further audit reuse and these are
detailed appendix two and three
um one of those audit reviews receives a
limited direction to travel
I'm quite happy to thanks any questions
um in relation to my report
Council shop
I'm referring to actually um internal
audit as opposed to external Waters so
basically we operate as internal audit
it's a number of days we provide in
terms of delivering our audit plans so
basically I have a team of Auditors and
we set out the work we're going to
undertake for the year so basically
in terms of my my staff we had reduced
numbers and couldn't deliver the
original audit plan so it's internal
audit not external what it is I'm not
talking about external I'm talking about
I believe uh Tim Willis can update you
on that one
yes thank you chair
um yes the independent person yeah yes
um yes it was it's recommended good
practice to have an independent person
on all the Committees that came before
this committee and this committee
approved uh the appointment of her
independent person or a recruitment
process being begun in time for the new
Municipal Year and that was last
November I believe
I think it went on to full Council as
well the decision
um so
um that hasn't been acted upon and
that's my fault it was it was downstairs
it was down to the section 151 officer I
have not done that yet
um I've spoken to
um the chair about this informally in
the lead-up to this committee
um and said that I expected it to come
up one way or another
um and what I can say is
um I just needed to get through this
committee and overview and scrutiny
tomorrow and then I'm embarking upon a
recruitment campaign to try and attract
an independent person to join the
committee
um I have the job description ready and
I have an idea where it's going to be
advertised nowhere very expensive
um and I'll also be inviting everyone on
this committee to let me know if anybody
they know that might be interested in
applying for the position there will be
a process around that and it will be the
chair and vice chair along with me in
accordance with the original decision
that chooses somebody if we can if we
can find somebody
um I'll just say that there was a point
where I said for the my Institute The
accountancy Institute that made the
original recommendations suggest that
there should be two independent people
um that that advice or guidance has
since been clarified by the government
and they say one as a sort of minimum
and most councils especially a district
council laotea level that would be
opting for one independent person and
that's what we're looking for we're not
sure how easy it will be attract to
attract the right person in any case so
if we can find one that we're all
satisfied with that we can recommend to
the to the Council on committee I think
I think we'll have done well so we'll be
starting imminently
um and then it will take for as long as
we can attract enough people to form a
short list to then conduct interviews
and make any appointments
thank you
I guess please uh
yes I can provide that thank you
councilor again thank you
um regarding paragraph 4.4 on page 6.3
I've got a couple of questions
um one around the potential data breach
from Capital
um it says here that the provided
details of their findings
um but there's no details in the report
I wonder if that could be explained it
can I ask a couple more questions to
save you going back up some forwards to
me
um the other question is do we have any
other
um
Partners the um third parties Partners
processing of data other than capital
and how do you seek assurances of data
processing protection
[Music]
in terms of data Bridge itself I report
was provided to the council by Capital
uh what what it suggested is that the
storage area where revs and Ben's data
was
accessible to people who shouldn't have
access to that storage area but they're
unable to identify whether that was
accessed so they basically are
suggesting that no data was pretty it
wasn't able to breach they suggesting
there wasn't a data breach so basically
they they provide a report to that
extent that basically you know there was
a potential for a breach but as far as
they're concerned there was not a day of
bridge
so it is a storage area where resin Benz
things are restored that people could
have had access to but as far as they're
concerned there wasn't a bridge of
resonance later
um in terms of other contracts I imagine
I presume there are other contracts
where their date has been processed on
behalf of the council I'm not sure what
what contracts exist um Tim might be
able to provide further information but
I imagine there are other contracts with
vendors that process date on behalf of
Rockford Council
um capital is the major one alternative
Ben stata
um but I'm aware we have a payroll
service provided by I think it's
Braintree Council so their process and
data on our on behalf so there would be
a a agreement in place in terms of
basically ensuring data is basically not
rich so there would be agreement between
Rockford and Braintree Council in that
respects so yes there are other event or
processing data in terms of what
insurance is um obviously we get um
we undertake orders ourselves but
there's also penetration penetration
tests undertaking by third party event
those who basically look at the
council's arrangements and test the
system
um testifiables you know can can our
systems be breached so we rely both on
our own internal Audits and also um
third-party
um work undertaking by other vendors who
are I.T experts and we also eventually
had a cyber security audit undertaken uh
um in 2223 by a third party called
elucidate who basically gave the Council
of clean Bureau health and the data
bricks we're talking about here Wars by
a third party it wasn't a result of
weaknesses in the council systems so
basically ask our systems to process the
fundamentally sound it wasn't as a
result of a failings on behalf of the
rotary Council so it's a third party in
that incident so
I believe based on the reports we've had
our systems are and our protections are
quite sound
oh yes okay can I come back and asked
how our Capital dealing with these
potential data breaches
um it's not the first one that they've
had so I just wondered what assurances
have we got from them that these data
breaches are being dealt with in those
in a way that protects us
I believe that Tim Withers can come back
on that okay
um thank you Jeff
um
Capital have provided a certain amount
of information important information in
relation to
um the data that was exposed if not
breached
um at the time
um in respect of Oxford Council and it
was names it wasn't what we would
classify as personal sensitive data
there are 93 cases
other councils were far more severely
affected and benefits information
personal benefits information was
exposed
um so we were not considered to be one
of the one of those worst affected by
the breach and we called you a breach
and we reported it to the information
and commissioner as a breach as did many
other councils
um capital of
because they say that it wasn't a data
breach they are reluctant to then take
lots of radical action to address what
others might consider to be weaknesses
in their data processing
um yes they have been subject to various
bridges in the past over the years they
do handle an awful lot of data so the
odds are that there will be from time to
time these things happening but
um I can't say I suspect any more than a
chief executive of capital could say
that this won't occur again
I know that doesn't give much Assurance
but um as a large organization that
processes a huge amount of personal data
there is always that that risk
um it would have been nice to have had
something more bespoke and comprehensive
for rogerford District Council but given
that we were only marginally affected by
this particular breach then I think the
efforts have been going into places like
Colchester and others that have been far
more severely affected
thank you
thank you very much uh Timmy for that
um are there any more questions about
cancer shot
yeah they're sort of Grant returns when
we're confirming basically we meet
conditions of the grant so basically not
provided there's no Assurance required
in respect to those because they're not
actually audits they're actually
basically just confirming the grant
conditions are met so so essentially we
don't provide a naughty opinion in
relation to internal audit of Grant
claims and one of those Grant places and
behalf are external audits so they will
bring a separate report on how some
benefit subsidies
um yeah so in terms of Grant claims we
don't give an assurance rating or what
required to do is confirmed basically
they make conditions of the ground
and we provide a return to that extent
thank you for that clarification
um page 6.4
um paragraph 4.8 I just wanted you to
just go through
um for me any concerns it says a lack of
effective corporate leadership
um we could be or a local Authority
could be experience serious governance
issues how does that affect us
um what it is is essentially during the
time of creation of strategic Partners
there's been a number of factory offices
that were imposed and these were interim
managers and that's largely been
addressed I think there's only one
interim manager now in place which is I
think is 10. so basically
okay okay
um so what we're suggesting during that
time is as like a stake of flux going on
and new managers new interim managers so
there's a loss of basically a previous
experience so what we're saying is
basically what we're looking for is
going forward is is a more stable
um senior management team
um
something I mean I can ask for Tim to
comment on on the situation as it stands
now
yes please
thanks Joe
um maybe I could just sort of speak on
behalf of the chief executive on this
point that I know there was a period
where there was Andrew Duncan who was
the monitoring officer and myself and we
were both into him
um and now
um Emily you're always the monitoring
officer for Rochford who's permanent
although she's not adopting that role on
an ongoing basis forevermore and they're
still an expectation then future that
that post even if it's newly configured
the post that Andrew Hunkin covered will
be recruited to
um so similarly the um Chief finance
officer post that I'm covering for on
the interim basis the plan is to recruit
that
um but something that um Jonathan was
pains to point out to others as well as
myself was
um I was originally employed for about
four months contract and
um given the prospect of some changes in
leadership of both of the councils and
given that there was a joint in section
151 statutory finance officer for both
councils
um he early on secured a contract with
me until March next year specifically to
see through a period of of uncertainty
and with new counselors coming along to
see through the 24-25 budget process
which I think was a demonstration of a
way in which he was mitigated in that
risk that my port is widely highlighted
in in his report
thank you
I have a question
um in on page 610 the items that are
deferred
um obviously these are
on your your work plan really with the
transformation team and
it's things like service review because
this will will evolve and develop
through the year as we're going all the
we did all of these things even the
climate change with the new committee it
will be be a budget for that and so on
so rather like having an ons hat on but
in audit as we go through this year
um do we get any heads up or
um on the progress towards more towards
the end of it because obviously it will
be in next year's report
because I'm just looking at it as like
overview
scrutiny we've got the independent
person we're hoping to hire there's a
sort of modern thinking in local
government you see where I'm coming from
with that yeah
just to get an update for that thing
yeah I mean in terms of different items
you get regular progress reports brought
to this committee so you get sort of
four progress reports towards during the
course of the year which then feed into
the end report so as we progress
internally audit plan during the course
of the Year you'll get um updates in
terms of where we are in relation to
those Audits and more people will be
speaking through service departments in
terms of how those Services views are
progressing because what we don't want
to do is obviously we we act as critical
friend over and above the internal audit
act so where they're looking at service
reviews and new control Frameworks we
want to get in early to confirm actually
controls or will work as intended so
because of these service reviews things
change so we have to make sure that
there's a good starting point but you
know we will want to thank audits at
some point in time so basically we are
looking to do once once the process is
embedded and working well within
undertake those audits but we do bring
us the same progress reports to this
committee so as we do those audios
undertake those audits you'll get
details of those audits
um we may find towards the end of the
year that even though they're deferred
to 23 24 it may still not be appropriate
time to do undertake those orders it
depends on how well the surface reviews
are going
so so essentially what we look to do is
provide a critical friend at the start
of the process to make sure the controls
are working and then we'll come back and
audit those surface areas at another
time
um yeah thanks very much because
obviously it's a learning curve for us
as well so it's in the new
Administration and seeing this evolve
um yeah thank you
are there any more questions
right um members um
there's one recommendation set out on
page 6.1 of the report that the chief
audit executive's opinion on the overall
adequacy and effectiveness of the
council systems of governance risk and
management and internal control be noted
is it noted members
thank you members
the next item is a gen gender item seven
which is the risk management update and
members Tim Willis the council's interim
director of resources will introduce the
report
thank you chair
um this report sets out the latest
assessments by the corporate leadership
team regarding the council's Strategic
risks
it's a different format to risk reports
in the past that have come before this
committee although most of the same
risks still apply
the last report on risk management was
to the 16th of November last year
there is a new risk since then of cyber
threat which has been included and is
considered very high
whilst the council is managing the
likelihood of the risk occurring
and indeed Mike Porter refer to this in
his annual report from from last year on
the Cyber Fair audit that there could
still be a substantial negative impact
on the delivery of council Services if
there was a successful and substantial
Cyber attack particularly in relation to
third parties
the risk related to the partnership to
deliver the asset delivery program is
also rated very high
this reflects the changing objectives of
the council since the partnership was
entered into
there's a review of The partnership
underway which is planned to report to a
future meeting of this committee
Additionally the council will be
receiving reports on proposed revisions
to the asset delivery program
until such time as these matters are
concluded there remains a risk that the
ADP will not be delivered as previously
agreed
and could I just apologize to members
that there are some missing scores on
the appendix appendix a the risk Matrix
with risk register
they where there's no scores for there
are scores for the previous scores but
there's no current score all of those
remain the same as the previous score so
did not want any commentary in the
covering report thank you happy to
answer any questions thank you
members if you have any questions
you will notice that although this is a
copy I've got to monochrome here is
actually color coded this year because
we requested that last year sure which I
think I was supportive of anti
so no questions
hmm
this is what is thank you I'll ask a
question
um of members because this format is
different from the previous format of
risk registers that have been received
by
Rossford Audi committees in the past and
what's happened since this was
um since November I conducted a one-team
review of risk and insurance which
identified those involved in Risk in
this particular case in Risk at Watford
and those involved in Risk at Brentwood
and came up with a new solution which is
to combine them under one person which
this is the first report
um that's obviously with my guidance
that's been brought before this
committee after that review has been
complete
um it had the assistance of the relevant
member staff
um Kelly O'Brien who previously would
have produced rochford's
um risk register and she and the new
risk and insurance officer Sue White
um have jointly agreed with me this new
format and the format obviously the
risks are different and the scoring but
the format of the report is the same for
both this Council and Redwood and it's
an example of how
hopefully we can deliver efficiencies
through the one team reviews whilst
retaining the best of each Council
um and I'm gratified that nobody has has
questioned the the format I think the
format is a bit cleaner and simpler than
what's been produced in the past and I
would just add that if if you look at
the last risk report that was produced
and those before it there were more
risks in the detail of the reports
that's because there were risks included
which are monitored below corporate
leadership team level they're not
strategic risks they're sort of
operational risks or projects or
contract risks those will all still
being managed that they're not just
being brought before you because they're
not the top risks of the council the
biggest risks that need the most
intervention by by Senior Management to
try and mitigate the the in the
likelihood and impact of those risks
thanks
thank you um council Mrs Wilson
thank you chair
um if I can direct my comment to Tim if
that's okay
um Tim I think the reason you probably
got no questions is because this layout
is very straightforward really
informative and I particularly like the
comments in the inboxes because when we
come back and review this risk register
that's an instant referral point which
actually is a lot clearer and a
straightforward than uh the last one
that I looked at for the council so huge
thank you from me
thank you very much the cancer shop yeah
I would certainly uh second that I
thought it was very clear and a
supplementary question does occur to me
and that is
are there any risks that are unique to
Rochford that are not shared by
Brentwood
Tim
um I should know this because I've just
finished writing bedwards for next
week's audience
the things like partnership is on both
in fact that wasn't on remember which
previously enough I've just put it on
Brentwood so it works both ways that
there's a risk in relation to the
partnership between the two councils
um that there will be obvious
differences that Brett would have
because they have a housing stock for
example
um I know cyber 30s on both
um I think probably one obvious unique
one there's probably some around
communities but I'm not that familiar
with the communities area
um but one obvious one is the
partnership in relation to the asset
delivery program yeah which
um its own challenges regarding
Partnerships but nothing that would
warrant the inclusion on the risk
register in relation to those
um and Brentwood will have a number of
other risks in in relation to things
that don't affect Rochford like a level
of debt for example which would have an
impact on the assessment of their
Financial Risk which don't apply to
Welsh but
thanks thank you
members I would point out on page 7.9
there is a risk ranking table and you'll
notice that we have a few High very high
risk items which are color-coded in red
but it does give us the recommended
review patterns for those in months
which is pretty clear really and gives
us a priorities really on
on the where decision making needs to be
done by the executive
which is their prerogative they were
thinking
and on that there will be another report
coming another this report coming to
your September committee
by which time we would have resolved the
decision-making process regarding the
asset delivery program partner as well
as hopefully there'll be some decisions
by then
um at Council I think in respect of this
asset delivery program as well so
certainly the asset delivery program
risk should be
should be uh much clearer and hopefully
a lower score by then if we have
favorable outcome
um the Cyber risk one
um I'd want to talk to my colleague
Sarah Benny about that
um I think in terms of very high risks
it's it's all about the impact on on
Cyber risks and I'd hope that we could
collectively come up with something that
could reduce the the likelihood score of
three which would remove it from the
very high risk risk because you multiply
livelihood by impact to get to the score
and then their score is as per the table
the risk banking table so bring the
score down
um potentially to medium if for example
there was one point knocked off the
likelihood so it could be that those
will come down but it's not to say
others won't appear well it's very high
but currently not very high and we can't
always assume that we'll eliminate all
risks and there will always be risks
um some will be very high risks but the
the value of this is this report
um as it is always going to be but it
gives you as members the opportunity to
see what they are and whether or not
you're comfortable with the action
that's being taken so one to two months
for very high risks well if it's three
months before the next meeting then that
should give an adequate time for us to
to compile
um a response that will satisfy you for
the next meeting
oh thank you um you might realize if you
want to look at on the internet that the
score table at the bottom on 7.9 it
comes from problem solving models the
uncertainty rule ruler you know the
wheel can definitely come off at one end
it's very unlikely the other and our
decision making is all about that
um I remember writing a bit of a paper
on that but nothing much happened at the
time but this embodies that kind of idea
and it's uh you may find that that ruler
might appear in Ernst and Young's
version of the report one it's out
um usually in the first couple of pages
so that's all to do problem solving
models which is what we're doing
and anyway I'll leave that
um anyone if any member got any other
questions
no right
um members there's one recommendation
set out at page 7.1 of the report
uh that the contents of the report be
noted
uh members is this noted
thank you thank you members this
concludes the business for this evening
and I've closed the meeting at us five
past eight five minutes I'll say thank
you